just as quickly as masks have come off
health experts are now recommending we
put them back on it's pretty clear that
there's more covet now than there was a
week ago and two weeks ago and we're at
the very early parts of a wave cases of
the omicron sub-variant ba2 sometimes
referred to as stealth omicron are
rising nationally in nova scotia and new
brunswick there's more healthcare
workers becoming infected wastewater
data from ontario and alberta has shown
an increase in the virus and over the
weekend covet hospitalization started to
rise in bc and that's not the only
province
when you see an increase in the
community cases as an indirect measure
you you have to be concerned
that there will be an increase in
hospitalizations and in fact at least in
quebec we are starting to see an
increase in the hospitalizations stealth
omicron has been blamed for a tsunami of
kova cases in china the uk germany and
france but only the latter has recently
experienced record hospitalization rates
another concern is ba 2's ability to
break through vaccination and re-infect
those who've already had covet dr
allison mcgear says the timing of this
wave for older canadians who are now
four to five months out from their
booster is concerning
their protection from severe disease
will have dropped from
somewhere in the 90s
right after their third dose
down to
somewhere maybe just below 80 percent
and while that doesn't sound like a big
drop
it's actually a doubling right the us
fda has approved forth doses for all
americans over 50. in canada it's
residents of long-term care and
immunocompromised adults who are
currently eligible it's not the answer
but it's part of this multi-layered
approach to trying to control cases and
obviously control severe illness and
death an approach we are all too
familiar with two years in but it's
whether we decide to react with personal
protective measures or choose to ignore
the warnings experts say that will
determine the impact of this spring
surge jamie morocco global news toronto